ma cosa dici io sono una dea è per
questo che pago le tasse sindaco fa
cagare
sapete che porta in patas qui ed è
bravissima a fargli vedere un po di base
a
ciao ragazzi bentornato in una punta di
vita buttata oggi mi farò un tè in
compagnia di daniela collu dani allora
io sono felicissimo diverti qua ti posso
offrire qualcosa di un alcolico da bere
si calcola che questo qui analcolico
quindi sentirai magari un retro retro
posto ma poi di base noi non c'è tutto
il resto tra parentesi non so se vedete
anche il match che è stato fatto
prostituta
ok qua veloci che partiamo con questo io
trovo adorabile questo ensemble e della
nonna ti ringrazio la perdizione kat
ovvero posso offrirti una zonetta
persona è un sentina mai
[Applauso]
dalla nostra alla nostra
la nuova puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
è importante però ti sei stato fabbro a
bergamo precedente ho avuto una
relazione in passato da me prima
relazione di questo ragazzo scivoli per
in vacanza per una settimana quindi
sacco crisi bene
notiamo
appena arrivati nella stanza
dell'appartamento amica io sono stata
lasciata in thailandia tra il primo e
secondo dopo cinque anni di relazione a
un giorno da capodanno e vivevo a casa
sua quindi capisci che roma non è niente
allora andiamo in vacanza in thailandia
facciamo una prima settimana di mare poi
andiamo a bangkok in un ristorante mi
lascia non è come è nato il po matto è
piaciuto sti nudo buoni santi c'erano 66
vecchia sei brutta sei grassa non mi
piace forse non mi sarei mai più
assoluta io gli ho risposto ma cosa dici
io sono una dea
quindi amica se cercate un bagno di
fiducia da me lo hai trovato io sono
sempre dell'idea anche quando si sta
insieme capisci tante cose della persona
con cui stai ma quando ti lasci capisci
tutto il resto cantona che al posto di
una cosa dopo 100 anni che faccio la
terapia di gruppo la gente mi racconta
essere sue io una roba ho capito non
esiste lasciarsi bene comunque una
settimana in cui vuoi la licenza
d'uccidere
e fare quelle belle cose con
lanciafiamme dalla finestra voi fa
mettiamoci l'anima in pace a volte siamo
stati con degli stronzi stronzi
siamo stati noi quegli stronzi
ma milioni di volte io credo che ci sia
un lato profondamente cattivo in meno io
so papa giovanni invece
nati perdono vai a fare le tue carte
altrove no no no io credo di essere una
persona che cerca di essere positiva
invece no sei satana ma c'è una parte di
me una parte ragazzi io ho una partner
che tu pensi che vendola vediamo questa
parte perché faceva da una parte i
dati rime anticamente serata arriva per
il e quindi inizia a fare caldo ma non
così cade con i pietro di porti l'ha
cercata
rendo forse ariano pagina nonostante
fosse coperta e viene proprio brutto da
dire lo squalo allora i primi a
gelateria al sito di forza di una
gelateria 8 reti peer to peer ed un
collo di genga golpe che faccio come
posso fare è tutto a posto conto che fa
più puntate davanti alla telecamera del
comune è per questo che pago le tasse ma
perché non chiedi se c'è un bagno e vai
a cagare al bagno come tutti in ora più
per questa cosa è fredda la pancia non
ho mai capito che ne abbiamo uno strato
di
nel senso tipo quelli che dicono non mi
far mangiare questo perché sennò poi sto
male io credo che se mangiassi questa
pazzia che adesso adesso io non avrei
problemi a rica garth la intera credo
con tutto quanto il gin tonic dentro
i miei più grandi figuracce che vede
come protagonista qualche anno fa
praticamente ma se vengono pare in cui
uscivo di solito incontro mio amico con
lui c'era una sua amica succede che
settimane dopo e l'incontro questo
nemico senza rendermi conto che la sua
vita fosse di fianco a lui mi ha detto
scusami a chi non sa struccata proprio
non riconosciuto innanzitutto fortunella
se queste qui la tua figura più brutta
ma la gamba i danni ai problemi della
vita che è così brutto dire tutto
riconosciuta senza trucco non lo so sì
lo è facciamo un esempio io vado in giro
sempre con la faccia tatuata c'è tutta
quanta nera per chi mi tengo dinero
seguito gli us in nero si rivestì cavolo
non ti ho riconosciuto perché
solitamente hai un trucco magari molto
forte molto scuro
metti che non è un trucco forti momenti
che non altro co scuro cioè mitica non è
una cosa scenografica ok questa si fa
quel trucco che nella sua testa è un
trucco invisibile magari pensa di essere
anche così abbastanza somigliante a come
previsionale quindi stai dicendo tu stai
automaticamente dicendo che il mio dirti
non ti ho riconosciuto vuol dire che
quando il trucco sei più bella io ho
detto che non c'è riconosciuto sta
giusto l'invito che ha detto di scusa a
mia mamma mi ha riconosciuto perché eri
una [ __ ] invece adesso mi è venuto sto
scaldabagno allora se tipo io adesso
tipo ti propongo scusa che è che sono
totalmente già andato e non si vede con
un occhio mi guardi con occhi più guardi
al piano di sopra passiamo segmento
giocheremo a un gioco e si chiama che
cosa sono io una dea
grazie
allora è rotondo verde fuori ci sono dei
semini dentro
rossa furia da altrimenti deve loro no
no anche un altro nome della curia si
dice a roma il cocomero grano nella
margherita c'è la mozzarella è anche
bravo e che cosa abbiamo detto che è la
margherita pizza bravo ma grande e
quando vai al cinese 3d che riempiono
tutto di soia quindi se di solito
gravissimo no vabbè che è quella roba
con cui cucinano soltanto dalla clerici
e nessuno si sa fare davvero niente
cucina esotica
no
lavori l'essere umano è un animale
sociale race e quindi sono un sociologo
vorrei si sa sono quello che chiami
quando voi ma fingendosi la vinci che
devo fare il vicini drowning esatto tu
sei proprio sono quello lì che quando tu
e male alla schiena
e alle ossa tra i cromatismi
infuocata a quel corso universitario e
noiosissimo
fuori gli capito quelli squadrati ed i
secchioni e santoni di recapito che
possa essere di lì
ingegneri ma ma sempre pescava con una
canna bassi invece fa da traino con una
rete
di reti [ __ ] e stampate scava con
una casa per adulti allora vai per
adulti sono stiamo insieme però ci
vediamo soltanto per kobe amici o anche
detti buddies
amici con benefici clinici con
interessi senza altra amici di letto
dopo quelli che mi sparo io di continuo
su instagram selfin bra come sono io beh
anche l'iconica ma che pazzesca ma anche
sexy è quello lì che viaggia nel tempo
nello spazio è un medico quindi un
dottore in inglese doctor chi ha davvero
è quello lì dove ti insultano in cucina
fi car e
quell'altro
certissima miranda
giro vestita male
città sapone di marsiglia si facevano
figlia la prima è simile al personaggio
di aladin sultan
gassman ha già far no iago no a mente
esatto poi abu dhabi esatto c'è il
partenone
atene si
garanza e se non è mosca è partito burgo
celebrità solo
anche andiamo jones
cosa regno di dio
george harrison mary's cosa
[Applauso]
portiamo a casa in sette paesi allora
presentatrice ma se proprio un [ __ ]
no quando cerchi di avere sempre ragione
la bravissima iniziava uguale parla il
brescia comunque semi riferirmi a terni
è un amaro amaro averna quell'altro che
bisognava salvare il vaso
l'antico base ci si fanno fare i
trapianti di capelli in ansia vicino a
nuova zelanda c'è un australiano più
corta quest'altra ge.se.sa straniera
inizio gara austria bresca tu sei pazzo
beh c'è partenone
bisogna dichiarare un vincitore beh se
bisogno di alcun vincitore
io sono una dea ha vinto lo sport e
l'amicizia e christian desidera
leggere di oggi ne vado a casa di questo
tizio a cena e lui con sativa piante di
marijuana in camera passiamo alla serata
insieme adesso a dormire lì nei giorni
dopo mentre messaggiano mi fa comunque
ci sarà un po di te in quelle piante
perché ho messo i tuoi capelli nella
terra e o all'impiegata di lui prosegue
perché affascinante come tutto possa
diventare nutrimento io anche quando mi
taglio le unghie all'evento del terreno
[Musica]
non l'ho mai sentito madonna che
immagino io mi devo scaldare quadrano
sia letta solo odio saluto sarà il suo
pollice verde non lo so questo
ho conosciuto un ragazzo a londra e roma
mentre ci dirigiamo un pochino versa la
sua casa mi fa io sono spacciatori più
famoso di salsa i continenti con una
donazione e io che non ho mai avuto un
grandissimo rapporto con le droghe c'è
proprio anzi un po intimorito ma cercavo
di fare la [ __ ] orate ok pazzesco che mi
fa scusa casa un po sporca io vi giuro
senso è entrato in una casa i piatti
erano per terra non sto scherzando
pensai questo questi ordina tutto quanto
a casa mette nei piatti e poi non
finisce mai e lì ho pensato noi italiani
comunque alla roba posizione lasciar
vivere bocciava goccia spia quando ad
una cena con mio fratello e mia cognata
degli amici e lui voleva
raccontare scherzosamente io avevo
imparato a cercare ha sbagliato e ha
detto sapete certa ha imparato a sky
ed è bravissima fargli vedere un po di
neve è partito subito
con cui si muove come si muore non si fa
una cosa bellissima
allora io purtroppo non ho dei commenti
da poter raggiungere e mi sentirei poco
galante a farti entrare all'interno di
un tipo di discussione questo tipo non è
più le consonanti non è che governo
toscano
non hai più le mentali le laziali c'è un
problema enorme che direi che la
portiamo a casa così con dignità e con
un'ottima cosa piace veramente che sei
stata mia grazie a testa da dea
ti posso dire che la vera idea to be vi
guarda grazie mille le tutti delle idee
siete tutti quanti ne dai ragazzi noi ci
vediamo sempre qui non so quando ma
comunque prima o poi accadrà ciao
[Musica]